WESLEY CHUN: Hi, I'm Wesley
Chun from the Google Cloud team,
joined by my colleague,
Martin, to welcome you
to "Serverless Migration
Station," where
each video shows developers one
modernization technique for one
of our serverless
compute platforms.
Today, our little
friend, Porter,
will take Python 2 App Engine
developers from Cloud NDB
to Cloud Datastore.
This is an optional
migration, so you
don't need to make this journey
unless you have a good reason
to do so.
MARTIN OMANDER: That
sounds good, Wes.
But wait.
My time is precious.
Why is this migration optional?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
That's a very good
question, Martin.
Well, legacy Python 2
App Engine developers
have traditionally used
App Engine's NDB library
to talk to Datastore.
In the previous
module 2 video, we
showed you how to move from
App Engine NDB and App Engine
Datastore to Cloud NDB
and Cloud Datastore.
That migration had
one specific goal--
modernizing App
Engine apps means
moving away from legacy
services to unbundled services,
because the original services
are feature complete.
So all innovation
moving forward only
comes with the newer,
standalone services.
You can move to Python 3, the
next-generation App Engine
service, and that's why
this additional migration
to Cloud Datastore is optional.
By the way, it's
just app migration.
Since App Engine Datastore
and Cloud Datastore
point to the same
database in your project,
no data migration is needed.
Review the module
2 video and codelab
to refamiliarize yourself
with our starting point.
The links are below, as well.
Let's pause for a moment to let
you review before moving on.
Because App Engine Datastore
and Cloud Datastore
point to the same
database in your project,
one great feature
of that migration
is that you didn't have to
migrate the data, only doing
the app migration in the video.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's right.
And not only did I
watch that video,
I helped you make it, remember?
Anyway, I know how to
migrate from App Engine
NDB to Cloud NDB now.
I'm also pretty sure you said,
by migrating to Cloud NDB,
I'd be accessing
Cloud Datastore.
But didn't you just say we're
migrating to Cloud Datastore
today?
If I'm already on
Cloud Datastore,
why would you want
me to migrate to it?
I'm confused.
WESLEY CHUN: Oh no, no.
It's not that.
Apologies for the confusion.
You're right.
In both cases, we're still on
the Cloud Datastore database.
But here, we're
talking libraries.
When Datastore matured to
becoming its own product,
the Google Cloud team created
a new native client library
for non-App Engine apps.
That's also where
we point Python 3
and other next-generation
engine runtimes.
Cloud NDB is made just for
Python 2 App Engine developers.
Today's migration is for those
considering that extra step
to going from Cloud NDB to
the Cloud Datastore client
libraries.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I
think I understand now.
You're saying that there are
two client libraries to access
Cloud Datastore, one for
long-time Python App Engine
users who prefer the NDB
style, while the other is
for those completely
new to Cloud Datastore.
Is that right?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes.
Essentially, that's
right, although Cloud NDB
can use with the next-generation
and Python 3 App Engine apps,
as well as non-App Engine
apps, meaning Python developers
have two options for
accessing Cloud Datastore,
depending on their preference.
Now the real question is why
you would consider migrating.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that's my point.
If both can be used for App
Engine and non-App Engine apps,
why should I even
consider migrating?
It'll require some
effort without much gain,
since I'm not getting
any new features
and generally expect
no changes to my app.
WESLEY CHUN: Yep.
That is absolutely
correct, which
is the main reason why
this migration is optional.
If your older App Engine apps
uses Cloud NDB to access Cloud
Datastore and newer
non-App Engine apps
use its native client library
and satisfy that everything's
working, there's really
no need to change.
The only reason you
would consider it
is if your organization wants to
consolidate to a single client
library for consistency shared
across all of your apps.
It'll reduce the size
of your code base
and the one common library would
become robust, because they'll
be used by many apps.
It would be fully-featured,
fully debugged,
and increased code reuse.
This makes code across apps
easier to manage and lower
maintenance costs overall.
However, if that's not worth
your effort, just stop now.
MARTIN OMANDER:
OK, I'll bite, Wes.
Let's say I want to do that,
or maybe I'll think about it
and I want to at least see
what this migration entails.
WESLEY CHUN: All
right, sounds good.
OK, everyone, same
drill as before.
Copy your module 2
cloud in the app code.
Or if you don't have
it, clone the repo
and download the zip file.
The only decision
you have to make
is whether you want to
migrate the Python 2
version of the app or Python 3.
These are in the module
2a and 2b folders.
You can also migrate the
Python 2 version first,
then port it to Python 3, which
is how the codelab does it.
We'll show you how to
do both in a minute,
but let's pause now so
you can go grab the code
and also pull up the codelab so
you can get hands-on experience
with this migration.
Let's go to the computer
and walk you through it.
It's always good to
start with a working app.
From your Python
3 module 2 folder,
run gcloud app deploy
to upload to App Engine.
If you're still in
Python 2, double
check that Flask
and NDB are in lib.
If not or you're unsure,
it's fine to delete
the lib folder and
reinstall, then deploy.
Your motivation to
upgrade to Python 3?
No more manual bundling.
Regardless, when deployed, point
a browser or curl to your app
and confirm the
output is the same
as from before, whether
modules 0, 1, or 2.
OK, now let's migrate
to Cloud Datastore.
The best part about migrations
is what doesn't change.
app.yaml and
appengine_config.py stay as-is.
Same goes for index.html
and templates.
For requirements.txt,
switch from cloud-ndb
to cloud-datastore.
Also add versions here.
I left them out of the video,
since version numbers change
all the time, and also, it's
different between Python 2
and 3.
Regardless, the repo will be
updated, unlike this video.
Python 2 developers must delete
their lib folders and reinstall
now, while Python 3
users can just chill.
When done, we can move on to
the main application file.
At the top of main.py, we're
importing and initializing
the API client for Cloud
Datastore instead of Cloud NDB.
We also have to add a
new import for datetime,
because Cloud Datastore doesn't
do automatic timestamps,
so we have to do it.
For store_visit(), NDB
acts more like an ORM,
or Object Relational Mapper,
where you declare a data model,
instantiate an object with the
desired data, then save it.
On the other hand,
with Datastore,
you create an entity,
specifying its kind as a key.
You get back a dict-like
object to add to your data
as key-value pairs.
Or in our case, we merge
an entire Python dictionary
into it, then save.
There's also no context manager
when using Cloud Datastore.
In fetch_visits(), you can
see querying is similar,
but Datastore is a
bit easier to read.
NDB favors chaining
methods together,
but Datastore has a more
step-by-step approach,
plus the convenience of getting
Python dictionaries back
without having to do
additional conversion like NDB.
And that's all that's needed
to migrate this sample
app to Cloud Datastore.
Save, gcloud app
deploy, and confirm
it still works just as before.
Let's go back to the
main presentation.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Thanks for showing us
that immigration, Wes.
It was good to see that
Cloud Datastore isn't
that different from Cloud NDB.
WESLEY CHUN: Of course, Martin.
It's true the code is similar,
but this is a sample app.
In real life, there are likely
more challenges, especially
related to complex queries.
So I've linked to the queries
pages for both libraries
so you can see more
differences between them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, I'm doing
the codelab on my own time.
I might need to see the Cloud
NDB and Cloud Datastore docs.
You got those links handy?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep, I
thought you'd ask.
Here are the links to both the
Cloud NDB and Cloud Datastore
docs, as well as to their
client library repos.
Finally, we linked to the
App Engine Datastore docs.
Don't forget the repo has both
the start and finish folders,
so you can reset back
to the 2a or 2b code
if you take a wrong
turn during the codelab
or want to compare
your answers with ours
in the module 3a or 3b folders.
By the way, if you're
still wondering
whether to choose Cloud
NDB or Cloud Datastore,
here are our recommendations.
Creating a new app in Python
3, App Engine or otherwise?
Go straight to Cloud Datastore.
Got a Python 2 NDB
App Engine app?
Migrate to Cloud NDB,
then port to Python 3.
Lastly, if using Cloud
Datastore elsewhere
and want a consistent codebase
using only one client library,
consider this migration.
If not, don't bother,
because Cloud NDB
works in both Python 2
and 3 with App Engine
or outside of App Engine.
So there's really
no need to move off
unless you have Cloud
Datastore code elsewhere.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
Thanks, Wes.
That was a really
good explanation.
It helps me make my decision.
By the way, on
another note, I also
heard that Cloud
Datastore was renamed.
Is that right?
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, Martin.
It's a bit more than that.
And I didn't want to distract
users from the main content.
But yes, it's true.
The next-generation datastore
service launched in 2017.
As it inherited some features
from the Firebase Realtime
Database, it was rebranded
as Cloud Firestore.
All existing Datastore
databases have
been upgraded under the covers
to Firestore in Datastore mode.
For new applications, consider
using the Cloud Firestore
in native mode.
We've given you a link to
learn more about when you would
choose one over the other.
Neither the Cloud NDB nor
Cloud Datastore libraries,
however, can access
those Firebase features.
You do really need to use the
Cloud Firestore client library.
If you have an app, App Engine
or otherwise, and at some point
down the road want to take
advantage of those Firebase
features, consider further
migrating to Cloud Firestore.
If interested,
check out module 6.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that's pretty interesting.
I didn't even know
about Cloud Firestore
and I will take a
look at that module.
That sounds like another
"Serverless Migration Station"
episode we can work on together?
WESLEY CHUN: That'll
be fun for sure.
What other migrations should
you consider for your App Engine
app?
If your app uses the original
App Engine task queues,
consider migrating
to Cloud Tasks
and check out
modules 7, 8, and 9.
If you're curious about
containerizing your apps,
check out the App Engine to
Cloud Run, modules 4 and 5.
Finally, if your average app
is simple, like our sample app,
consider migrating
to Cloud Functions.
More on that in module 11.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds like a
lot of options for our users
out there.
Happy to be working with
you to help guide our users
and show them best
practices, Wes.
WESLEY CHUN: Sounds
good, Martin.
And that wraps today's optional
migration to Cloud Datastore.
On behalf of Martin
and Porter, this
is Wesley Chun
from Google Cloud,
and we look forward
to seeing you
at the next "Migration Station"
or on another "Serverless
Expedition" soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]